The rise of the state is a key point in
the the evolution of human society.
Most of the research and certainly in the social sciences has been
directed at what happened. But both...in a sense the why and how questions have not been tackled with the same level of sophistication
as the what question and this project wants to explore and see if they are
regularities in the in the evolution of early states.
But also we want to know why in similar circumstances in other parts of the world at different times and places the state
did not arise.
The earliest states
probably
degan, in what's now
referred to as lower Mesopotamia in modern, modern day particularly center in in Iraq and
in neighboring areas. Probably around
3,000 BCE or a little earlier. I think one of the fascinating
topics for us in this project is to look at what are often referred to as primary states. That is states
beginning in areas where there are no predecessors.
And this probably happened at least six or seven times in in world history. I think
legitimately, we can say that a state
involves the beginnings of
large-scale
bureaucracy and administration and in different levels in the hierarchy of administration and the
control of such
hierarchy by
an elite who also has
some kind, of course, of power via standing army or other ways to enforce the
kind of the rules and laws that this bureaucracy
comes up with. And what's fascinating when you look at these pristine states
and then other examples of secondary states that arise, there seems to be
significant patterning in
the way, they arise. So what we really wanted to find out are their commonalities that we can actually come up
not only with a clear model and an explanation of
why and how they arose but literally if we can actually come up with a quantifiable model
that's predictive. Our current understandings in most general form of the rise of early states, is that they
develop in the context of
competing chiefdoms that is small, smaller scale groups
in a given landscape who are competing for resources...
for labor and so on and it's in this competitive environment
that the kind of the next step that allows one of these
competing groups to succeed and ultimately take over
the others. That's how states arise, part of it is is military skills and mobilization of
significant, well
cooperating groups, but also the ability through trade
you need to have to support both the elite
themselves and also the elites ability to to mobilize
forces, and then the build up of administrative organization to
effectively control areas that might have been taken over by military conquest.
It's an effect the the
higher level of organization that one of the competing groups is able to achieve that gives it the ability to
out-compete if you will of the the other chiefdoms. What are the key variables?
clearly
conflict,
competition for resources are important.
But there may well be a host of others in in the realm of ideologies in the in the realm of politics
You know let alone
economics, and also the general role that ecology and landscape may play as well. That is a
large complex adaptive system in each case. In today's world one of the exciting things for
archaeologists are the
quantity of terrific data from a number of
individual sites or regions throughout the world.
What we've lacked and what our Templeton Foundation project is going to tackle is trying to compare these many cases on a
global basis and see if we can find common processes that led to the rise of the state and early cities throughout time and space.
Part of our project is to build a database on all the available
archaeological data about early state development that we can put our hands on. A
number of SFI scientists have been looking at different aspects of the rise of the early states and the cities combining
perspectives from
cultural anthropology, from archaeology, from history
but also using modeling from biology, from physics and a host of
disciplines. Obviously looking at new
methods particularly computer simulations.
And it's this project will bring all of these different approaches together. Where we hope will be a really productive and important result.
Why study the state? What's so important? And the answer is really twofold. One is its inherently interesting.
I think historically to understand how states and cities first arose but just as importantly and I think for many of us we feel it
understanding and explaining the rise of states and cities will provide us with new perspectives on the problems facing the world today.